MIKE WEST: Good afternoon.
I hope you all had
a good lunch.
I hope it was as tasty
as mine was.
I'm glad you all have shown
up for a talk like this.
It's relatively specific.
And I'm hoping that means that
all of you are very interested
in the topic and will have some
really good questions
afterwards.
This will be about 45 minutes.
And then I'm going to try to
leave a good amount of time at
the end for questions, because
there are a lot of things
going on in the extension
space.
There are a lot of things that I
think are really interesting
and that are going, I think,
to have a little bit of an
impact on the way
that you develop
extensions going forward.
But before we get too much into
that, extensions are kind
of awesome, aren't they?
Extensions are great because
they allow you to customize
the browser in ways that we
simply couldn't do when we
distribute the browser
to a broad audience.
Extensions give you the ability
to personalize the way
you interact not only
with the web but
with the browser itself.
A good example of this is me
building this presentation.
I used an extension called Clear
Cache by a guy named
Benjamin Bojko.
This is an extension that's
really quite excellent.
And it's really, really good
for web developers because
what it does is, you click a
button, it clears your cache,
and then reloads the page that
you're currently looking at.
This is really, really helpful,
astoundingly so, actually.
And what's really interesting
about this is that it actually
has powers above and beyond
what we would
give to a normal website.
It's able to actually dive deep
down into the browser and
use some APIs in order
to remove data.
Or, if it was a different
extension, to change settings
or something along
those lines.
I think we'd all be pretty
surprised if we went to a
website and it suddenly cleared
my browsing data.
That would be a bit odd.
What's interesting about these,
however, is that we see
a little bit of bloat in
the extension space.
We see a little bit of bloat
in a couple of ways, two
distinct ways.
First, we see extensions that
are actually requesting more
permissions than they actually
need to do their job.
If we look at Clear Cache, for
instance, we see that even
though it's only clearing my
browsing data, it actually
requests host permissions
to the entire internet.
It does this for a very
good reason actually.
It does it because it wants
to clear cookies on an
origin-specific basis.
We don't yet have an API that
allows you to do that, which
means that the only mechanism
that the developer actually
has at this point is to request
a large and dangerous
permission in order to do a very
small and focused task.
This is something that we
definitely want to fix.
And there are a lot of things
in the extension system that
we think we can fix
along these lines.
The other area that we see
bloated with regard to
extensions is the resource usage
that extensions actually
use when they're active
on your computer.
We'll talk a little bit about
how we're going to try to
address both of these issues
in a little bit.
One last thing we see in the
extension ecosystem is the
fact that while extensions
themselves are quite secure--
and we think we have a really
good handle on dealing with
explicitly malware
extensions--
we see problems with regard
to extensions that
are benign but buggy.
This means that the extension
itself is doing things that
are quite important.
And it's doing things in a way
that simply opens up a hole or
two within the extension
process itself.
This is a bit problematic
because, as we said earlier,
extensions have permissions that
go well above and beyond
what's available on
the open web.
This makes extensions a
juicy target indeed.
We'll talk a little bit about
how we're going to address
that with the concept of
Manifest Version 2.
Manifest Version 2 is something
that was introduced
in Chrome 18 as the first set
of breaking changes in the
extension system.
Manifest Version 2 basically
is exactly the same as
Manifest Version 1 with a little
bit of extra stuff
layered on top, a few
restrictions but also a few
new abilities.
We'll talk about those now.
The attacks that I talked
about earlier would look
something like this.
And these are the sorts
of things that
we're trying to address.
Extensions dive deep into
a web page by injecting
JavaScript.
This injected JavaScript might,
for instance, in a
mapping application or a mapping
extension look for
addresses on the page
and try to do
something useful with them.
It might want to
display a map.
It might want to go out to the
Google Maps API or something
along those lines.
It grabs this information via
inner HTML and passes it to
the background page
via a message.
The background page or a pop-up
or anything along those
lines might then try to use this
information by injecting
it into the background
page or into a
pop-up using inner HTML.
The problem happens when
this information isn't
well-processed, when you don't
really ensure that you're only
getting information that you can
easily and safely inject
the inner HTML.
If, for instance, the website
injected some script tags
inside of the thing your
extension is looking for, then
you've got a big problem because
at this point you've
just injected untrusted script
into a high-permission area of
your extension.
This is a big problem,
in fact.
It's something that a team of
researchers at University of
California at Berkeley have
found exists not really to a
really wide margin within
the extension system.
They went through about 100
extensions and found
vulnerabilities like this
in about 40 of them.
However, they found that 94%
of the vulnerabilities that
they found-- which included
either loading resources over
HTTP as opposed to HTTPS or
the sort of inline scripts
injection issue--
would've been solved if both of
these issues could somehow
be removed.
We think there's a
way to do that.
And I'll talk about it
in just a moment.
Manifest Version 2 introduces,
then, two large changes that
we think are going to help make
the extension ecosystem
more secure and a couple of
small cleanup changes.
The two big changes are a
default content security
policy and web accessible
resources.
Manifest Version 1 is, as of
Chrome 18, deprecated.
We'll talk a little bit about
the schedule that we have in
mind later on.
Manifest Version 2 is very
easy to opt into.
It's simply an attribute inside
of your manifest file.
You say, Manifest Version 2 and
then we know that you're
opting into the new system.
The structural changes are
very straightforward.
First of all, we've made the
background property a little
bit smarter.
Instead of creating a background
.html page that
really contains nothing except
script, you can simply inject
scripts by using the scripts
property inside background.
You could load a library, load
your main.js and go without
actually creating an HTML page
that doesn't do really
anything at all other than
load these scripts.
And also, we've made some
cleanup within the APIs
themselves.
For example, we had
chrome.extension
.getTabContentses.
That's not actually a typo.
That was part of the API.
We've removed that.
Instead, you should use
extension get Views.
There are a couple of other
places where we've combined or
we've removed pluralization that
wasn't necessary, things
along those lines.
If you go to the extension
documentation, you can see a
complete list of all the API
changes that happened.
Let's talk, then, about the
first of the two big changes.
The first one is Web Accessible
Resources.
Web Accessible Resources gives
you a mechanism of determining
exactly which resources inside
your extension should be
available outside the context
of your extension.
If you need to inject a script
file or an image or anything
along these lines into a
website, what you'll need to
do is actually specify
that resource within
your manifest file.
Here we've shown web accessible
resources
public.png.
public.png loads, private.png
fails.
So at this point, you simply
have the ability to whitelist
the specific resources within
your extension that are
available outside the context
of your extension.
This solves a couple
of problems.
For instance, we've seen a lot
of extension developers using
the query string on a options
page or a background page or
something that gets
loaded in order to
actually do some work.
It was then impossible to script
that page by loading it
outside the context
of the extension.
This will remove that sort
of vulnerability.
Content Security Policy, then,
is the second of these two
large changes within
Manifest Version 2.
This is probably the
biggest change.
And it's something that I'm
going to spend a good amount
of time on walking you through
because it's very important.
Content Security Policy gives
you a mechanism of mitigating
the risk of cross-site scripting
attacks by very
specifically whitelisting the
origins that are allowed to
load resources inside of
a certain context.
In this case, we're defining a
policy for extensions that
enables you to determine that
origin one-- so my website--
I should be able to
load resources.
I should be able to load script
from that website.
I shouldn't, however, be able
to load resources from the
evil.example.com.
If somehow people were able to
inject code into my background
page that tried to load
resources from an
unwhitelisted origin, it
would simply fail.
This gives us a good measure
of security.
And it's something that we're
really excited about, not only
for extensions but also
for the open web.
There's going to be a really
good talk on Friday that I
think you should all attend
if you're at all
interested in security.
And really everyone should be.
There's a lot of
detail on this.
I'm not going to go into a
whole lot of detail about
Content Security Policy itself,
how it actually works,
and how you define a Content
Security Policy.
We've just published an article
on HTML5Rocks, which
is an excellent website
by the way.
If you go there, you can get
a really good overview of
Content Security Policy.
And I think that's probably a
good use of 10 or so minutes
of your time.
The default Content Security
Policy that we're defining
within the context of Manifest
Version 2 is script src self,
object src self.
This has a couple of impacts.
The basic idea is that you can
only load script from inside
of the context of your
extensions, so inside your
extension package coming
from the same origin.
You can also only load Flash and
other plug-in information
via the same mechanism.
So these sorts of things we
would like you to bundle with
your extension when possible.
It has a couple of
impacts then.
First, no JavaScript can be
loaded by default from third
party servers.
No objects can be loaded
by default
from third-party servers.
No inline JavaScript--
this includes script tags.
It also includes things like
inline event handlers in
JavaScript URLs.
It's simply impossible, you
see, to differentiate code
that was injected maliciously
from code that was inlined in
your web page intentionally.
There is no difference between
the two as far as the HTML
parser is concerned.
It's simply impossible to
make that determination.
And the Security Policy then
takes the safest route, which
is banning it entirely.
No eval, this is an
interesting topic.
And we'll talk about it a little
bit more later on.
But for the moment, by default,
eval is disallowed.
This includes not only eval
itself but also things like
new function, set timeout that
uses a string, and set
interval that uses a string.
So anything that takes strings
and converts them directly
into executed JavaScript is
something that we simply can't
allow within the protected
context of the extension.
Ideally, this means that we'll
be free from XSS attacks
within the context
of the extension.
That probably isn't
completely true.
But Content Security Policy gets
us a heck of a lot closer
to that than we are today.
So let's talk in a little
bit more detail
about third-party resources.
I said that by default you
aren't allowed to load
third-party resources.
This is the case.
You can, however, loosen this
policy to include HTTPS
sources, that is secure
HTTP sources as
opposed to HTTP sources.
If you go to a coffee bar and
hook up to their wi-fi, you
really have no guarantee that
anything you load over HTTP is
actually what the
server sent you.
It's incredibly trivial to
go in and manipulate that
content, injecting new content,
or changing it entirely.
HTTPS, however, is an entirely
different story.
Because it's encrypted, it's
much, much more difficult to
inject anything malicious
into an HTTPS string.
At that point, we feel pretty
good about allowing you to
load things like Google
Analytics over HTTPS as
opposed to HTTP.
So if there are third-party
JavaScripts that you need to
load within the context of your
extension, we would ask
you to specify within the
Content Security Policy that
you define for your extension.
You could write something like
this, script src self, which
means you can load things from
your own extension's origin,
but also https://ssl.goog
le-analytics.com.
This will enable you then to
load Google Analytics, do the
things you need to do with this
external library, but do
it in a very safe way.
We'd actually, however, be
thrilled if you locked things
down even further than the
defaults that we've set.
You can start with a default
source of none, and then list
every single type of resource
that you need to load and the
origins associated with
those resources.
This gives you a much--
a higher degree of security than
simply using the defaults
that we've set.
The defaults take care of the
most dangerous things, that is
scripts and objects.
But if you want to deal with
everything else as well, we'd
be quite happy.
Inline JavaScript, however,
is something that we
simply can't loosen.
This is actually the core of
Content Security Policy.
Because you can't differentiate
between
maliciously injected code and
non-maliciously intentional
code, we simply can't allow this
policy to be loosened.
If you have code that looks
something like this, it's
actually not really best
practice anyway, right.
We have JavaScript,
CSS, and HTML.
But all have very different
purposes.
HTML is there for markup.
CSS is there for your
presentation.
And JavaScript is there
for behavior.
Separating those out into
separate files makes your code
easier to understand and is
really best practice anyway.
If you haven code like this, you
can very easily rewrite it
into two separate files.
So instead of having an inline
event handler on a button, you
would have an external
JavaScript
file that gets loaded.
This JavaScript file would hook
up an event listener.
And at that point, when you
click on the button,
amazingness will still happen.
You'll get the exact
same effect.
But you'll get it in a way
that we can ensure safe.
Eval, on the other hand,
is a bit problematic.
We can't really allow it by
default because your extension
might be working with untrusted
data coming from users.
So user-generated data being
potentially turned directly
into executed JavaScript,
that's problematic.
And it's simply something that
we can't allow within the
context, within this
high-permission
context, of an extension.
We understand, however, that
it's pretty important for a
couple of use cases.
There are a few of you that
really, really need to use
eval and especially eval-like
constructs.
New Function, for instance, is
used in a wide variety of
templating libraries.
And we understand.
We've heard the feedback that
that's incredibly important to
the way that many
of you develop.
We think we have an alternative
or a work around
for this that we're happy with
and that we hope you'll be
happy with as well.
The idea is that you create a
sandbox in which eval can
execute in a non
dangerous way.
Let's talk a little bit about
how that might work.
We have your extension.
And inside of your extension,
you create an iframe.
This iframe is sandboxed,
meaning that it has fewer
permissions than the
extension itself.
We defined in the previous
page sandbox.html.
We load sandbox.html
in an iframe.
It's then pushed off
into a separate
origin from your extension.
This means it doesn't have
access to any data that your
extension has stored.
And it doesn't have access
to the dangerous
chrome.star name space.
So any of the things that your
extension can do, you'll need
to deal with the sandbox in
much the same way that you
deal with content scripts
and injected scripts.
You'll pass messages into the
sandbox containing data that
you'd like to see processed.
Then you'll pass processed data
back out of the sandbox
into your extension giving you
the ability to, for instance,
pass on a context for a template
and get templated
HTML or rendered
HTML back out.
At that point, you can inject
that HTML into your pop-up
page or into your background
page without worrying about
whether it's dangerous or not
because that new HTML, that
newly generated HTML, would
then be executed inside a
context that's protected by
Content Security Policy.
Even if an attacker was
completely able to hijack
everything within your sandbox
HTML file, the worst they
could do is present links or
something that would be useful
for a user or that looks useful
for a user to click on.
They couldn't actually
execute any code.
They couldn't exfiltrate data.
At that point, we're pretty
happy with this as a
compromise.
The code for this would look
relatively straightforward.
As I said, you would inject
an iframe-- in this case,
sandbox.html, which again was
defined in the manifest file
as being a sandboxed file.
When this file is loaded, you
would fill that iframe with
templating goodness.
So at this point, I'm using
something like Handlebars.
Many of you are using different
frameworks.
They would generally
work the same way.
You want to inject or you want
to code a sandboxed page that
contains all of this templating
information and
then create sandbox.js,
which has--
will basically create an API
on top of your sandbox that
allows messages to be passed in
with a certain command and
a certain context.
Then you'll be able to execute
that information.
So I create a template at
the top of the page.
This is just the way
Handlebars works.
And then I listen for
a message event.
When a message event comes in
with the command of render,
then I post a message back to
the extension containing some
templated data.
So I execute template with the
context that I passed in.
This gives me new HTML.
I pass it back out.
And I can do whatever
I want with it in a
relatively safe way.
That side would look
like this.
When I click on the browser
action, I pass information
into the iframe content
window.
And I get the information back
out as a message event.
This gives me the ability then,
as I said, to sandbox
the way that eval works.
This means I can do the
dangerous things.
But I do them in a context in
which those things are no
longer dangerous.
The Support Schedule for
Manifest Version 1 is as
follows at the moment.
Chrome 21 is coming out
mid to end of August.
At this point, no new extensions
built using
Manifest Version 1 will
be accepted in
the Chrome Web Store.
It's not, however, the case that
old extensions at this
point will have any problems
whatsoever.
Old extensions will be
grandfathered in.
If you currently have an
extension in the store that's
using Manifest Version
1, you're fine
for a little while.
But this is our message
to you.
Manifest Version 1
is deprecated.
We really need to move to a
system that is more secure,
that gives us these guarantees
in a way that we
simply can't do now.
We've had Content Security
Policy in the extension system
for a while.
And it simply hasn't gotten
enough adoption for it to be
useful for us as a security
mechanism.
We're going to need to migrate
extensions over to the new
Manifest version.
And we're doing it with
a schedule as follows.
Chrome 23, Chrome will stop
packaging Manifest Version 1.
This means if you want to
package a Manifest Version 1
extension for distribution
outside the Chrome Web Store,
you won't be able to do it
through Chrome anymore.
You'll need to write something
on your own.
Some time in Q1 2013, we're
looking at Manifest Version 1s
not appearing in search
any longer.
This is the point at which old
extensions are going to start
seeing impacts from this.
Some time in the middle of Q--
of 2013, Manifest Version 1
items will simply be unpublished
from the store.
We're going to be publishing
warnings about this.
We're going to be sending
emails out about this.
We're going to make it very
clear what's going on.
And we're very much hoping that
we can get you guys to
come along with us.
In 2013, whenever we're happy
with the way things are going,
we'll turn off Manifest
Version 1
inside of Chrome, period.
This means even extensions
that are loaded within--
in Enterprise, for instance,
will simply not work anymore
in new versions of Chrome.
So we're definitely looking to
move people over relatively
quickly for Manifest Version
1 to Manifest Version 2.
We're really looking for
feedback about this.
We want to know what the pain
points are so that we can make
the system better.
We've heard your feedback with
regard to templating.
We think sandboxing is a
good alternative there.
If there are other pain points
that are really causing
problems in this migration, we
really want to hear about it
so that we can fix it and make
it easy for you guys to
migrate from one to the other.
We've talked a little bit about
Manifest Version 2.
It's a big change.
It, however, has a lot of
benefits that we think are
really valuable.
And it also is going to enable
us to build new APIs that are
more targeted.
And these new APIs, we think,
are going to be really
interesting for developers.
Let's talk a little bit
about some of them.
So, many of the APIs that we've
produced over the last
three years in the extension
framework have been very much
like chainsaws.
They're large.
They're powerful.
But it's relatively easy to
sever a limb if you're not
being careful.
What we'd like to produce is
something much more like
X-Acto knives or scalpels--
something that's very fine in
detail that gives you the
ability to do the things that
you need to do, but do it in a
way that's much less dangerous,
that doesn't
require the same permission set,
specifically with regard
to host permission.
What we also want to do,
however, is reduce the number
of resources that are
used by extensions
on an ongoing basis.
You see here that I have--
and I have a lot of extensions
installed.
I've basically installed every
Google extension that I could
find on the first couple of
pages of the Chrome Web Store.
What we see here is, first
of all, it's relatively
difficult to use.
But if we look at the Task
Manager, we'll see that all of
these extensions--
even though they're doing
absolutely nothing right now--
are taking up a large number of
resources, anywhere from 20
to 30 meg, depending
on the extension.
It isn't quite as bad
as it sounds.
Much of this memory is
shared because of
multi process model.
But it's still much more than we
think extensions should be
using when they're not doing
anything at all.
We'd like to kill off
those processes.
And we'd like to shrink the
amount of resource that's
being used an ongoing basis.
The mechanism we are looking
at for doing
that is event pages.
We published a blog post on
Chromium.org about this, I
think, last week.
The idea of event pages is that
they work very similarly
to background pages.
But they disappear when you're
not actually using them.
So we can kill the
process entirely.
This has a large number
of benefits.
First of all, by killing the
process, we ensure that even
if there's a leak somewhere in
your extension, by killing
that background process, we
can also kill the leaks.
So even if there's a leaky
extension, we reclaim all of
those resources simply by
reaping the entire process.
It also gives us the ability to
move to a more event-driven
model, something that we think
is really going to be useful
for low memory devices,
like Chrome OS.
If you're looking at a
Chromebook, it's not going to
be possible for you to load
hundreds and hundreds of
extensions if each of them is
taking up memory in the
background, regardless of
whether they're active or not.
We want to make sure that on
these low resource devices
that we point those resources
towards the things that you're
actually doing as opposed to the
things you might be doing.
Event pages are opt-in.
And it's very straightforward.
When you use the new background
page syntax, you
simply write, persistent
false.
So you set this flag to false.
And at that point, your
background page will simply be
killed when it's not doing
anything useful.
The life cycle is as follows.
We load the background
page on installation.
At that point, we record all
of the events that are
registered within the
background page.
So your background page might
look something like this.
It might be a main.js.
You might register for
a couple of events.
Chrome will remember and persist
all of these events.
Then when your background page
is killed, we can start it up
again based upon these events,
based upon user interaction.
So in the middle, I register
for chrome
browser action unclicked.
Chrome will remember this, even
when the background page
isn't there anymore.
If I click on the browser
action, it'll restart the
process, spin it back up again,
and execute or pass in
this event so that I can execute
something useful.
You'll see two new events,
chrome runtime on installed
and chrome runtime on suspend.
Chrome runtime on installed is
triggered on installation but
also on every update.
This gives you the ability to
determine whether or not the
extension is being installed
for the first time, which
gives you a good opportunity to
use the Chrome storage APIs
in order to set some values, to
do some set up, to set some
flags or whatever it is that
your extension actually needs.
But on update, you can also
do things like migration.
So if you're using index to be
in the background, you could
at this point check the version
of the current database.
And if it's the old database
then migrate to the new one.
So this, we think, is going
to give you some good
opportunities for dealing with
these sorts of events that
were difficult to deal
with in the past.
Chrome runtime on suspend is
called when the background
page is about to be killed.
So when Chrome recognizes that
the background page isn't
doing anything-- it doesn't have
any pop-ups open, you're
not inspecting it at the moment,
it doesn't have any
active network requests, and
things along these lines--
will go ahead and send an
on suspend event to the
background page.
You'll have a little bit of time
here to do any sort of
last minute saving.
This isn't a good time to start
uploading 10 megs of
data to an external server.
You should be saving
as you go.
Basically, you should be ready
to die as soon as this thing
is called--
or your process should
be ready to die.
You, of course, should
not be ready to die.
Chrome runtime on suspend
will be called.
It'll execute.
And then some arbitrary period
of time later, your process
will be killed entirely.
It'll be spun back up
again when any of
these events are triggered.
It's not, however, the case that
you can only respond to
user driven events.
Some of your writing extensions
that need to go out
to the web, pull some data,
store it locally, and then be
ready and responsive
for your users.
We've then created an Alarms
API that works exactly for
this use case.
At some point in the future,
you can wake your extension
back up, do some processing,
and then go back to sleep.
For example, you can create
a period in minutes, which
simply means that your extension
will be triggered
every 10 minutes
at this point.
Every 10 minutes, you can go out
to the web, pull some new
information, store it locally,
and be ready for your user's
response whenever-- or ready
to respond to your user
whenever they actually interact
with your extension.
You can do this as a one off,
as a repeating, or at some
specific point in the future.
We give you a lot
of options here.
Another area in which we see
extensions actually requesting
more permissions than they need
is keyboard shortcuts.
Key bindings, at the moment,
are a big mess
in extension land.
To bind to a specific keyboard
shortcut, you have to request
host permissions to all URLs,
so the entire internet.
Then you inject a content
script that
listens for key presses.
And you really, really hope
that this content script
doesn't actually interfere in
some way with the application
that your user is running or get
overwritten in some way by
the application user
is running.
We can do much better
than this.
Our attempt at doing better is
the keybindings API, which is
currently an experimental.
The keybindings API is a
declarative API that allows
you to say, I want to respond.
Or I have a couple
of commands.
And these commands should be
associated with specific
suggested keyboard shortcuts.
This is--
should be, I think, be
relatively straightforward.
You define a list of commands.
Each of the commands
has a description
associated with it.
And each of the commands has
a list of suggested keys.
You can set up different
suggested keys for the default
or for a specific platform.
We think this gives you
a lot of flexibility.
Inside of your extension will
look a little bit like this.
You'll hook it into the on
command event of keybindings.
And, at that point, you'll
get a string.
And that string is going to be
the same string you defined in
the manifest file.
You'll get this command.
You can respond to it
in some useful way.
What you might have seen is
Execute Browser Action as a
specific command that will
allow you to execute the
pop-up or execute the On Clicked
event of your browser
action with a keyboard
shortcut.
This is something that hasn't
been possible before, even by
injecting content scripts.
And it's going to be a big
benefit, we think, of moving
over to the keybindings API.
You'll be able to, for instance,
just do a pop-up by
executing some keyboard
shortcut.
There are a couple
of to-dos here.
It's not done.
As you notice, it's
an experimental.
Mac support is simply
nonexistent at the moment.
We're working on it.
But it's going to take
a little time.
And we also don't have any UI
for dealing with conflicts.
We have some UI for assigning
shortcuts.
But it's just not there yet.
We actually just implemented
saving last week.
You could look at
it beforehand.
But this week you can actually
save new keyboard shortcuts.
So we're getting there.
Slowly but surely.
Let's talk a little bit
about network APIs.
There a couple of really
interesting APIs that we've
released over the last year.
And the usage of those APIs has
surprised us in some ways
but is also, we think, pointing
towards things that
we can do in the future
to make things better.
That future thing
is going to be a
declarative web request API.
To understand why that's
important and why that's
valuable, let's first talk a
little bit about the web
request API that exists today.
The web request API looks
something like this.
In this case, I went to block
my user from going to
malicious websites.
As we all know, malicious
websites have an evil=1 as the
last get parameter.
I mean, it's great.
It's really useful that they do
this because it allows us
to block their requests.
Blocking their requests looks
something like this,
chrome.webreques
t.onbeforerequest--
so before the request is
actually sent out of my
computer to do something
useful.
You see the last item here
contains a few flags, in this
case blocking.
This is the first synchronous
API that we've created.
And the synchronicity of
the API is a little bit
problematic for us.
It's problematic for the
following reasons.
Chrome looks more or
less like this.
We have a browser process that
manages a wide variety of
renderer processes.
Each tab, more or less, has
its own renderer process.
So, if a web page wants to load
a URL, if they're using a
web request API, the web page
will say, OK, I'd like to load
this image.
That request will be sent
up to the browser.
The browser they need to make a
decision should the web page
load the image or not.
To make that decision, something
it sends a message
down to the extension.
The extension--
or the message then hops from
c to JavaScript in order to
make the determination to do
something useful to execute
this code up above and then
sends that information back to
the browser process.
In parallel, it's sending these
requests out to all the
extensions that have registered
for a web request
that filters into this
specific request.
Sending all of this information
back and forth
between the processes
is costly.
It's more costly than we
actually expected it to be.
If you go to Chrome histograms,
you can see
exactly how costly it
is on your computer.
I created a bit of a
torture test here.
But, you see-- actually, you
probably can't see because
it's really small.
But at the bottom here, the
longest request or the longest
wait between sending a message
from my page to the extension
and back was over two seconds.
Now, this isn't typical.
Most of the requests are
happening in well under 100
milliseconds.
But over two seconds to
process a request is
incredible.
That's much longer than it
should actually take to load
the resource in the
first place.
We need to do better
than this.
And we think we can.
The declarative web request API
is a declarative mechanism
for determining whether or not a
request should be blocked or
redirected or anything
along these lines.
You declare a declarative
web request permission.
And you create a series
of rules.
You might do this in the on
install event of your
background page.
You create a rule.
Rules contain conditions
and actions.
If the request matches
the condition--
so if they're going to
evil.example.com--
then we're going to
block the request.
Once we've created this large
array of rules, we add all of
the rules into Chrome.
And we can do this incredibly
efficiently.
Adding the rules to Chrome
standardizes the way that we
deal with network requests,
giving us the ability to very
efficiently store the
information in the browser
process as opposed to pushing
everything down to the
extension process.
This has a couple
of advantages.
First, we don't have
to do so much IPC
messaging between processes.
But second, because we've
defined a single mechanism for
declaring these sorts of rules,
we can do it very, very
efficiently indeed.
You can set conditions
on basically every
piece of the URL.
So you can look for ports.
You can look for paths.
And you can look for
query strings.
You can also look at the
entire URL if that
suits your use case.
We haven't yet added regex
for the entire URL.
We're working on that.
What we have added, however, is
a variety of conditions--
or, I'm sorry, a variety
of actions.
The actions that are associated
with these URLs
are, for instance,
cancel requests.
This is probably the
most common.
You simply don't want
to make this request
in the first place.
You don't want to send
any information out.
What we also all you
to do is redirect.
And you can redirect not only to
a specific URL, but you can
redirect using a regex.
For instance, you could redirect
all HTTP requests to
the exact same request
on HTTPS.
Unfortunately, it isn't quite
that simple, which is why
HTTPS Everywhere exists.
But we think this is going to
give extensions like HTTPS
Everywhere the ability to create
this really complicated
rule set without actually
jumping into JavaScript in
order to make that
determination.
We also give you the ability
to deal with the request
headers and the response headers
that you can set and
remove headers simply based upon
the URL that the user is
actually going to.
You can ignore rules.
So if you're familiar at all
with email, you've probably
set up a bunch of rules.
And you have things like, if
this, then do this and ignore
the rest of the rules.
This allows you to set
a priority with
each of these rules.
So when you create really
complex rule sets, multiple
things might match.
And you want to make sure that
the right thing actually
executes based upon
that action.
So you set a priority
with the rule.
And at the end of your actions,
you can say, ignore
any other rules that are lower
priority than this one.
The act of tab permission is the
last new thing that I want
to talk about today.
The active tab permission is
something that we think is
going to be really
quite powerful.
It's something that we, I think,
are very excited about.
What it does is allow you to
deal with specific hosts
without requesting permission
for those hosts.
We see a lot of extensions out
there that really only need to
interact with the page the user
is currently viewing.
For example, Google has a
dictionary extension, which
allows you to grab a word out
of a page and give you a
definition for that word.
It's incredibly useful.
But in order to act, it injects
content scripts into
every page that you go
to and then listens
for a browser action.
When you click on the browser
action or use a context menu,
it then grabs the thing that
you've currently selected,
does something useful with
it, and displays
the result to you.
It has to request host
permissions to every website
on the net in order
to do that.
Active tab permission would give
it the ability to, based
upon a user's gesture, inject
script into a page that it
hasn't requested permissions
for.
In this case, I would request
permission for
active tab and tabs.
You'll note that I'm not
requesting any host
permissions at this point.
I can, however, listen
for a browser action.
I could also listen for a
context menu and act upon that
action by injecting script
into this page.
We're using the user's
interaction with either the
browser action or the context
menu in order to give the
extension the ability to inject
script into this new
context, even though it hasn't
explicitly requested
permission for it.
We think this is going to be
really useful, not only for
the Google dictionary extension
but for the wide
variety of extensions that we
see in the Chrome Web Store
that are looking for exactly
this sort of functionality.
We see many extensions that
really don't need permission
for the entire web.
But they don't have any other
mechanism of doing it.
We'd love to see people
experimenting with this.
It's in canary right now.
It'll be in dev relatively
soon.
So we've talked about a wide
variety of things.
What do we actually want
to see happen?
And what do we think that we can
do together as a community
in order to strengthen
this ecosystem?
The first thing is to really
take a hard look at Manifest
Version 2 and start migrating
extensions over to it.
Manifest Version 2 gives us
really good guarantees about
the way that the extension can
function and the security that
comes along with that.
If we ban inline JavaScript,
there's a huge win associated
with that, not only for us but
also for the users that are
using extensions at the
end of the day.
They get a safer ecosystem.
And they can more easily install
extensions with the
understanding that those
extensions are safe.
We'd love to see people start
migrating over to Manifest
Version 2 and, as I said,
talking to us
about the pain points.
We've really heard what people
have said with regard to eval.
We've created a work
around for that.
That's the model that we'd like
to see going forward.
We really want to understand
what the problems are that you
guys are going to face when
you're building extensions in
the future under these
new restrictions.
You can report issues either
by filing a bug at
new.crbug.com or by hopping onto
the Chromium extensions
mailing list.
So you can send an email
to chromium-extensi
ons@chromium.org or subscribe
to the mailing list yourself
if you'd like to do that.
That's via groups.google.com.
We'd then like for you to take
a look at the new APIs that
are coming out.
In the past, we've had the
concept of experimental APIs.
We're going to start doing
away with that slowly.
Instead, we're going to start
experimenting via channels.
That is, an API will be
available in dev but not in
beta or beta but not stable.
This, I think, will give us a
much larger audience for the
new APIs that are coming out.
Instead of only targeting the
users that have set the
experimental flag-- that means
they've gone into flags,
they've set experimental and so
on, which is a very small
number of people indeed--
you'll be able to target
everyone who is
on a certain channel.
So everyone using dev can start
installing extensions
that are using these new
privileges or the new
extension APIs that
are coming out.
And as soon as that moves to
beta, your audience broadens
even further.
We think this will give you the
ability to start playing
around with extension APIs
earlier without forcing your
users to do something
that they're not at
all comfortable with.
That is going in deep into
Chrome and setting some sort
of flag that they don't
understand.
Finally, again, we'd really love
to hear what the issues
are, what the pain points are,
what we can address, and what
we can address together, what
the things are that are really
going to be problematic going
forward because we want to
solve these things.
We want people to start using
the new Manifest version and
the new APIs.
And that's simply not going to
happen if there are blockers.
So we want to understand
those blockers.
And we want to fix them to
the best of our ability.
You can contact me at
any of these places.
So I'm on Twitter, I'm on G+,
that's my website on GitHub.
Or you can send me an email
personally, mkwst@google.com.
I'd be happy to hear from you.
And I'd be happy to hear from
now if you have any questions
or comments.
[APPLAUSE]
Sorry.
There are microphones
in the middle.
So if you can walk over,
then everyone
can hear the questions.
AUDIENCE: So I have two
questions, if that's OK.
MIKE WEST: Yeah, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
So what's the-- but with these
background pages that die when
they're not--
MIKE WEST: Event pages, yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the preferred
practice for push
notifications to Chrome
extensions?
MIKE WEST: Push notifications
will be events
just like any other.
That is, you can subscribe
to them.
Chrome will recognize that
you've subscribed to them.
And when one comes in, you'll
get an event notification in
exactly the same way that
you would before.
There really should
be very little
difference with event pages.
It's just subscribing to events
and dealing with that
subscription.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
My other question is, I can't
help but notice some parallels
between, like, malicious Chrome
applications being out
there and malicious Android
applications.
And the Android team at Google
has made Bouncer, which for
those who aren't familiar, it's
a dynamic analysis tool
that runs your Android code.
And if it detects malicious
behavior, it
rejects you, basically.
Do you see anything like this
in the future for Chrome
extensions?
MIKE WEST: As I said, I think
we're pretty happy with our
ability to deal with malicious
Chrome extensions, the
extensions that are actually
doing damage intentionally.
The thing that we find much more
difficult to deal with
are the benign extensions that
are doing really good things
but are doing them in
dangerous ways.
These sorts of things, we think,
are better addressed
simply by applying a policy to
the extensions that forces
them to do things
the right way.
I hope that answers
your question.
AUDIENCE: Sounds good.
Thanks.
MIKE WEST: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to have tighter integration
for having my web application
detect that you have an
extension installed and
be able to have
them communicate together?
Because right now, if I want
to pass information between
extension and my page, I have to
use an inner HTML with some
random element on the page.
MIKE WEST: I mean, if you have
an extension that should
interact in some way with
a page, you can have an
interaction point--
well, I mean, you can send
messages to the extension.
So if you have a defined API,
you can send messages over.
You would have to have
that endpoint as a
web-accessible resource.
So that's where the new
stuff would come in.
What we would also suggest is
that you use the inline
install mechanism.
That would actually enable you
to install the extension if it
isn't already installed
on the website.
So you could prompt the user and
then install it directly
from the page without hopping
over to the web store.
AUDIENCE: And one more
question is, is
there any plans to--
for example, we wrote a Chrome
extension that would let users
give us feedback about an
application or if they
experienced a bug with our
application, they could send
us a screen shot basically of
what they were looking at when
it happened.
We wanted to be able to get
access to the console log from
the extension so that we could
see what error they got.
Is there any plans to get that
kind of information available?
MIKE WEST: Within your
background page, you should be
able to use window.onerror in
the exact same way that you do
on web pages.
That would give you any
errors that happens.
And you'd be able to report
those in the same way that you
can on the open web.
AUDIENCE: But not like, for
example, informational
messages, debug messages
we might output.
MIKE WEST: No, if you're
outputting the messages, then
you could package those
up in some way
and save them locally.
And then if an error occurs,
you could send them.
But there's no mechanism that
the extension framework itself
gives you to make
that possible.
MIKE WEST: Got you.
Thanks.
MIKE WEST: Yeah.
No worries.
AUDIENCE: As the Android is
having the Chrome browser, do
you guys have any plans
for building the
extension for the Android?
MIKE WEST: There's nothing to
announce at this point.
It's difficult.
And it's difficult.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Nice talk.
I have a question about
the permission.
It's really cool to have
permissions and extensions.
That's very cool what
has been done.
But for the normal user,
everyone's saying-- you know
that when you have in Chrome Web
Store, you have all these
permissions saying, old
browser history,
every single thing.
Is that going to be taken
care of as well?
Like the whole point of us
putting all these permissions
in our extensions right now,
it's going to be more work for
us to figure out we need.
But it would be cool if the
Chrome app store says, oh,
this user's using web sockets.
Or this user's using those kind
of new HTML technologies
that you're exposing this
website or exposing this
hacker website and
stuff like that.
MIKE WEST: I think what I should
have made clear earlier
is that by not requesting host
permissions, we can actually
make the permission messages
much less scary.
Instead of requesting permission
to the entire
internet by having, you know,
all URLs as part of your host
permissions, if you only
request active tab--
because that always goes through
a user gesture--
we actually don't have
to show a permission
warning at that point.
The permission is explicitly
granted by the user when they
directly interact with
your extension.
AUDIENCE: That's
on the timeline
to fix up the messages.
MIKE WEST: It's on the timeline
in that we're going
to create new APIs that
are less dangerous.
And those new APIs will come
with less scary permission
messages because they simply
are less scary.
AUDIENCE: And my next question
is, I like the on suspend and
on install, because before we
used to do them version check
all the time.
And for the on install, is there
a way to know if it's
updated or installed without
doing a local storage check?
MIKE WEST: No, you would have
to set something locally.
AUDIENCE: How about
the on suspend?
Is there a way to revoke
suspension?
MIKE WEST: No.
AUDIENCE: So we can't
do event preval--
MIKE WEST: No, if your extension
is suspended, it's
going to be suspended unless the
user interacts with it in
some way or unless it's being
kept alive by either having a
long network request --
AUDIENCE: So there's no way to
wake it up instantly, like--
MIKE WEST: That would
be the alarms API.
So you can say that at some
point in the future, I want to
wake up again.
So inside of the on suspend
event , you could certainly
say, you know, in five minutes,
wake me up to do something.
But that would be
your mechanism.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
MIKE WEST: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are there any updates on
detecting when a user
uninstalls an extension?
MIKE WEST: None that
I know of, no.
That's definitely something
that we can talk about.
I'd suggest, if there's not
already a bug filed, file a
bug and send them to me.
AUDIENCE: It's there.
MIKE WEST: OK.
Send me the ID, if
you don't mind.
AUDIENCE: I can do that.
MIKE WEST: I'll take
a look at it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MIKE WEST: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Question about
potentially selling
extensions, do you-- is there a
plan in the store to extend
the apps, like purchase ability
APIs into Chrome extension?
MIKE WEST: There's nothing
to announce.
I don't know of any plans.
AUDIENCE: OK then, a subset to
that, what would Chrome's--
or, potentially, what would
the thought be on,
hypothetically, bundling an app
in the store and the app's
sole existence just be a license
file that I can sell
and then use the Chrome
management permissions to
check the existence of
installation of both and
thereby shoehorn some way
to sell an extension.
If I managed to do that, would
that somehow get me kicked out
of the store?
MIKE WEST: It sounds
interesting.
AUDIENCE: All right,
well, [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE WEST: That's the
first I've heard of
something like that.
So--
AUDIENCE: Currently, building
cross-browser extensions
across different browsers
is a pain.
The more and more we use
advanced Chrome APIs, we are
alienating ourselves from
Safari and Firefox.
I'm not even talking about IE.
Like browsers-- even like Safari
that chooses that kit,
we are alienating ourselves.
Are there any plans from
Chromium to prescribe a base
set of APIs or form a consortium
so that these are
some basic APIs that
should be present
across all the browsers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIKE WEST: Part of the issue,
I think, is that extensions
really enable you to dive deeply
into the way that a
browser works.
And they're really well bound
together with the way the
browser itself works.
I think there probably would be
value in figuring out some
way of dealing with extensions
in a cross-browser fashion.
What we think, however, is that
extensions are really
based on web technologies.
And to whatever extent possible,
you should be
building things in HTML and
CSS and JavaScript.
And those sorts of things,
especially the back end
portion, should be reusable
across browsers.
I think you can look at
extensions, like HTTPS
Everywhere, that have presence
on multiple browsers.
And what they've basically done
is create a library in
the back end and then put a
thin shell on top of that
library that lets them target
both Firefox and Chrome.
We think that's a pretty
successful model because it
enables them to do the things
that they do really well--
building this library--
and then allow the browsers to
do the things that they do
really well by having specific
APIs for each.
But you're entirely correct.
It would be nice if everything
was the same everywhere.
That's simply not where
we are right now.
AUDIENCE: I have another
question about extending on
the malicious extensions.
Say if an extension currently
requests x number of
permissions and on a remote
update it's going to access
more permissions to do
some thing that it
shouldn't be doing.
Are there any things
to prevent that?
Like, say, one of the--
it might not be intentional.
One of those popular extensions
are putting
affiliate links on
Google search.
Like, basically, it could put
a content script and do
anything it wants.
What are steps from those?
MIKE WEST: Currently, if an
extension requests more
permissions, then it'll be
disabled on update until the
user specifically enables it.
So, they'll get an info bar at
the top of-- or, actually,
it's not an info bar anymore.
It's a pop-up that says, this
extension requested more
permissions.
It's been disabled.
And you can re-enable
it from that menu.
So it gives you the ability to
determine that the extension
is now requesting more
permissions and to evaluate
that based on what you know
that the extension does.
What we'd also like to see is
people moving more towards
optional permissions, which we
introduced a few months ago.
I'm not exactly sure
when it came out.
But, by having optional
permissions, we don't actually--
if you request new optional
permissions in a new extension
update, we don't give you this
info bar because it actually
doesn't change the way
the extension works.
But it gives you the ability
then to explicitly request
those new things from the user
when the time is right.
So geolocation--
for instance-- if I need to
interact in some way with a
user's location, I can make
geolocation an optional
permission.
And then when the user actually
interacts with the
extension and needs that new
permission, I can ask them
then, when it's really quite
relevant to the way that
they're working.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MIKE WEST: Thank you.
Go ahead.
OK, one more.
Two more.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I work
at Genentech.
And we are trying to deploy
Chrome for Business for all of
our employees at Roche
and Genentech.
I was wondering--
and we also have--
currently, we just use the
consumer Chrome browser and
build extensions on it.
Are there any limitations to
using Chrome for business as
far as building extensions
goes?
Or is it just the exact same
sort of functionality?
MIKE WEST: You actually have
a really good mechanism for
deploying Chrome inside
of Enterprise.
So it's very Enterprise ready.
You can deploy it as an SI
package and deal with
corporate policies via,
you know, like Active
Directory or something.
Via Active Directory you can
actually set a list of
extensions that should be auto
installed or that are banned
within the context of
an organization.
So, by using group policy in
the same way that your IT
department is probably quite
familiar with, they'll be able
to deploy Chrome locally and
actually deal in a very
detailed manner with the
extensions that are
pre-installed and also the
extensions that aren't allowed
to be installed.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MIKE WEST: Thank you.
Great.
Thank you very much
for your time.
If you have any questions later
on, I'll be at office
hours pretty much
all the time.
So just come hang out.
We'd be happy to answer any
questions that you have.
Thank you very much.